-Our next guest is a prolific
filmmaker and screenwriter
who just won the New York
Film Critics Circle Award
for Best Director for his
epic action drama film "RRR,"
which is currently streaming
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-[ Screams ]
♪♪
[ Grunts ]
-Please welcome to the show
S.S. Rajamouli!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, S.S.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you. My pleasure.
-I -- The same thing happened
to me watching that clip again
that happened to me
the first time I saw this movie,
which is at some point
I realized my face hurt
because, without knowing it,
I was just grinning ear to ear,
because I had never seen
anything like this film.
And my only regret
is that I watched it at home.
I watched it on Netflix.
And you --
I heard you speak about
what one of your films is like
on an opening weekend in India.
Can you just talk about
what the crowds are like
when they see a movie like this?
-What we just heard now,
in 200x.
Yeah, basically, the fans
will be tearing up newspapers
all through the night,
making huge bags of confetti,
and they come to the theater.
And the moment
the actor's name is displayed
or the actor comes in
or they anticipate
their favorite star
is coming onto the screen,
all the confetti
will be thrown into the air.
You won't --
You won't see the picture,
and they'll be laughing
and shouting so loudly,
you can't hear the sound.
The projector operator,
who is not supposed to meddle
with the sound,
he will be increasing
the db of the sound.
But still
you can't hear anything.
-It is a -- It must be amazing,
and I assume that
that is your goal, right?
Like, it is so -- Again,
the audacity in this film,
the things I saw in this movie
that I --
Again, I've seen
so many action films.
There were five, six
different set pieces
that went beyond
my wildest imagination
of what you could accomplish.
That must be the goal
you set out to achieve,
which is just to shock
and delight people.
-Absolutely.
But the initial thing
which I talked about --
the confetti
and all that stuff happens
for almost all the star films
in the beginning.
What I want to achieve
is that happening
even after the 10th day
or the 11th day
or happening outside
my country in the U.S.
Not the confetti part,
but the enjoying part.
And like you said, I want
my audience to be astonished
and really thrilled
about the astonishment.
-This is sort of
a historical epic.
It takes place in 1920.
We saw a couple of
freedom fighters there.
It's a wonderful
friendship story,
and, you know, it's about them
revolting against British rule.
Was this an idea you always
had in your head
to do something like this?
-Not always,
but I had an idea of --
always had an idea
of doing a multi-star.
Not just bringing
the stars together
but bringing
two heroes together.
Right from my childhood,
I had these ideas of --
Whenever I read stories,
different stories,
I like bringing those
heroes together and --
and making up some scenes
with them.
Sometimes I'd also be
in that scene in my head.
I always liked to do that.
And when I saw
"Inglorious Basterds"
in the theaters
and when Hitler was suddenly
shot with a machine gun,
I thought,
"Wow. This is really -- Wow."
I mean, we know he clearly
didn't die that way,
but it's fiction, you know?
It's a fictional movie, and you
can take liberties with that.
And, yeah, putting those
two things together is the --
-I will admit I had never seen
either of your stars before,
and yet the first time either
of them came on screen,
I knew that is
a gigantic movie star.
And I have to assume
I'm right about that.
-Yes, they are.
They're big stars.
-Were they -- I mean,
they're the most charismatic,
fun-to-watch pair I've seen
in a movie in so long.
Were they both on board
with this idea of,
"Oh, we can do this film
with S.S. where we team up
and it's sort of a two-hander
as opposed to just one star"?
-I worked with them before,
and I had --
We had successes,
big successes.
And apart from the
professional relationship,
we have a personal friendship.
And they, too, are friends
outside their professional area.
So when I wanted to do
this multi-star,
what I did was -- I knew
if I called one of those,
he will call the other person
before I can call him.
So what I did was
I just called each of them
and I said, "Why don't you
come out to my place?"
They didn't have an idea
of why I was --
why I was calling them.
So they just came over,
and they were surprised
to see the other in my place.
And I said, "Okay, guys."
I took them to my balcony
and said,
"Okay, guys, I have this idea,
and I'm putting this to you
both at the same time.
I want you to do a multi-star
with you. Are you up for it?"
I didn't tell them the story.
I didn't tell them
what I'm going to make
because I also didn't have
a clear-cut idea
of what I was doing
at that point.
Yeah, it was a nice coup,
and it worked.
-Yeah. Well, well done.
Can you tell us
about the title, "RRR"?
Is that something you had
from the beginning
and what those R's stand for?
-[ Laughs ] That's funny.
That's not the title
we had in mind,
and when we announced
that all three of us
are going to work together,
we had to put --
give out some name
to refer to the picture.
So we took the first letters
of our names,
Rajamouli, Rama Rao,
Ram Charan --
and we just put #RRR.
It was just a name
to refer to the picture,
not actual the title.
But the fans started
with the title.
They loved the title.
The distributors of our films
loved the title.
They said, "This is the title."
So we didn't know what to do
and said,
"Okay, guys.
'RRR' can't be the title."
So, we have many languages
in India.
The film is dubbed into
five languages in India itself.
So we put a competition
for the audiences, for the fans,
saying that you expand
the title.
So we have that title for each
region, for each language.
But the common title
will stay as "RRR."
-You obviously are
a really established director.
You've had nothing but success.
I would assume you've never had
quite this response
from the West.
What has it been like?
You know, I saw you win
this award for Best Director
here in New York,
and, obviously,
I saw footage from people
responding with great fanfare
as they saw it in theaters
in the States.
Has this been exciting
as this has become sort of
a worldwide phenomenon?
-"Exciting"
is an understatement.
It is -- I'm in --
We are on the top of the world.
I essentially make films
for Indians in India
and across the globe.
But when we started getting
appreciation from the West,
our initial thought was,
"These guys must be
the friends of our Indians
who went to watch the film."
[ Laughter ]
Then as it started increasing
when the celebrities,
story writers, film directors,
so many people
started tweeting about it,
talking about it --
the film on the social media,
they started championing
for the film by word of mouth,
we thought, "Okay,
this is growing much more."
Then it released on Netflix,
and it was on the top ten
for 15 consecutive weeks.
It released in Japan.
It's still running in Japan.
This is the highest-grossing
Indian film ever in Japan.
Oh, my God.
-I should note a couple
of Golden Globe nominations,
as well.
You got that.
-Yes.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know, it is --
I feel it gets so hard
to see something
that you've never seen before,
and that is how I felt through
the entirety of your film.
It is just such a joy
to have you here.
Congratulations to everything.
It's so well-deserved.
I really, really appreciate it.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
S.S. Rajamouli, everybody.
"RRR" is currently streaming
on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."